the Joe Rogan experience in the valley
all that whole strip you gotta be
careful what you walk into you gotta be
careful the place I go to which is
[ __ ] tremendous look at this I'm you
know just to show you look at that my
punch card is full now all right it's
the whole foot spa I go in there it's
all guys and one chick and the chick is
built like me and if you need a massage
they got like whatever down the street
they got they got all the to advice they
got all the time massage ty and what's
the other one that's big at Sioux no
it's it's a white new corporation
Massage Envy uh-huh all those places are
on this block listen you go give this
little Chinese chicken junk for the 40
spot and then give her a lay a $60 tip
on it cuz it's 44 45 minutes I give her
$60 tip she's on me for a now I leave
they're [ __ ] dizzy well she's
tremendous tremendous they usually have
the one they have that they have a
[ __ ] happy I got turned on Fujitsu go
they do the elbow on your back and all
that stuff I got turned on to this by
God Alberto crying he goes bro you you
want the best massage in town I'll show
you and like I live right across the
street live right around the corner from
I could walk there if I want you going
there some nights I going on date night
with my wife we want a date and we would
take sweats and we switch there and we
go and they pull your things they
[ __ ] put your feet in the buckets
they rub you down they do your shoulders
your neck sometimes I had only one
people rub my feet I got that [ __ ]
fungi toenail you little [ __ ] Chinese
hands on my fungi don't know they just
let it die the [ __ ] more people oh no
I said [ __ ] let me just go as if you
were patient zero what's that you were
patient zero if they're rubbing your
feet and then it spreads all these
people and they have all trace it back
yeah yeah I'm the [ __ ] I got the
fun right so now I even got the groove
on to get a blow-torched feeling because
you go up in the valley and the lady
comes she sticks a thing in the nail
and they blow hot another lady comes in
and they got masks it's hysterical
and she comes in would blow it cold
they're like Carol bird crowd therapy
TypePad mm-hmm and the other chick comes
with a blowtorch and they try to blow
the fungus away you gotta smell that you
gotta smell that Oh so I did like six
appointments where they tried to burn
the fungus off oh my god this doesn't
work the toenail was on fire no it
spread to the other one so now I got the
big one and the one next to it alone and
here's the ugliest thing in the world
looks like one [ __ ] host from an
eagle Jitsu I try to hide it with a
band-aid but it cuts right through the
band-aid it's horrible I don't know what
I was to do I had to take a medication
but I don't know if my kidneys can
handle it because the blood pressure
medication oh you can't you have to take
a fungi thing that zaps it but I took
one that I tried to zap and it still
didn't kill it
is there anything you could apply
topically or does it have to be a pill
they talked I've done everything I've
done everything the apple cinnamon cider
Clorox I dip it in I wrapped it in a
[ __ ] Cloris and it's great because I
cut it with the best thing I do is I cut
it like some nights when I'm bored I got
it and I take the grinder - and I grind
it into like coke powder and it grinds
down you have to smell that powder -
believe it well it is so stinky and I
just touched and oh Jesus Christ and I
have to wipe down the [ __ ] counter
and throw it away
but I will grind those first two toes
it's like a [ __ ] thing
like like your standing your toes oh
yeah it's a sand I got the extra rock
for like I had my wife go on Amazon and
get like the [ __ ] [ __ ] Obama stone
yeah yeah bodies and I just [ __ ] sad
that [ __ ] toenail down
oh I don't even know Jesus Christ I
don't know where I got it it's internal
and you know its internal you because
that's how the fungus is coming out of
you oh so it's in your body and then it
just comes out through your toes so it
can come out other spots yeah but I'm
not getting it on my nails and nothing
like that it's just from that one fungi
toenail
what if it came out on your balls duh
listen I'm at the age you know that like
no point we only want your wife to suck
your dick no Mac then that sack is
[ __ ] longer than that this [ __ ]
nightmare
I don't know how women could suck an old
man dick does that look at my dick in
the mirror when I go like the Vegas to
get those good mirrors when you you're
at home you look it looks the way it
does everything cuz you're used to that
mirror right it's not that you going
away him you walk back your walk past
[ __ ] on a vacation or something when
you're on the road working you walk past
the mirror and they catch you like I'm
getting a little fat like the real hotel
mirrors don't [ __ ] around
it's all right there but when you look
at 56 my dick has been through a hell
it's got holders you haven't smelled it
smells like Newark Staten Island it's
kind of the P is different I mean the
smell you pee lately I'm trying not to
come when the element either was saying
drink his breathing give him a shot on
my feet this [ __ ] this will
poison you when I wake up in the morning
that first dose of P is the worst
smelling thing in the world before I go
to bed I drink water a little bit of
Thai cherry juice and I'd take a [ __ ]
baby aspirin because the high level
after 50 is to get the heart attack
between 5:30 and 12 I was making a
mistake in thinking that aspirin at 7:00
it's too late you gotta bother
if you take that before you go to sleep
it's better for you I gotta ask you this
[Applause]